[Music]
the cricketer ollie robinson was
suspended from the england team last
week after it emerged that he had put
out racist and misogynistic tweets when
he was a teenager
he released a video apologizing for the
comments have a look
on the biggest day of my career so far
i'm embarrassed by the racist and sexist
tweets that i've posted over eight years
ago
which should today become public i want
to make it clear that i'm not racist and
i'm not sexist
i deeply regret my actions and i'm
ashamed of making such remarks
i was thoughtless and irresponsible and
regardless of my state of mind at the
time
my actions were excusable since that
period i've matured
as a person and fully regret the tweet
today should be about my efforts on the
field and the pride of making my test
debut
but my thoughtless behaviour in the past
has tarnished this
so does the punishment fit the crime or
is this another example of cancel
culture getting out of control
to discuss i'm joined by douglas murray
the spectators associate editor
and james forsyth the spectator's
political editor james can you talk us
through what happened
so ollie robinson is a 27 year old
cricketer now plays for sussex
and he made his england debut uh in uh
last week's test match between
england and new zealand uh he took a
couple of wickets but at the end of the
first day's play it came out that
when he was a kind of 18 19 year old he
he
sent a bunch of crass tweets um bad
taste jokes uh and
uh that was particularly embarrassing
for the ecb because the england world's
quick board
because all the players before the game
had lined up wearing kind of
anti-discrimination
uh t-shirts then at the end of the match
in which uh robinson was probably one of
england's better players
uh the ecb announced that they were
suspending robinson from all
international cricket
pending an investigation i think what is
particularly
tough here is that robinson is is now 27
and he didn't have an easy start to his
cricketing career and he was sacked by
yorkshire uh because of kind of poor
timekeeping and general bad attitude
so while he hasn't been punished
specifically for the tweets that he sent
you know he has paid a price for that
phase in his life and the kind of
general lack of seriousness
in his approach to life and i think
that's why the ecb's punishment
feels disproportionate douglas robison
has
explicitly apologized for the tweets
which he admits were wrong
you've written that this saga shows that
we are unforgiving in the way our
society is treating people now
what do you mean by that well the first
thing is as james just referred to the
fact that this should be done on what
would have been
uh robinson's proudest day of his career
to date
his first day uh playing for england
in uh such a test match and uh i think
it's
uh for a lot of people it just looks
like
an extraordinarily retributive thing to
do the timing is so
vengeful and going back to what james
has referred to in the actual story
we're talking about
tweets from 10 years ago
bad taste jokes basically banter from a
young man who seemed not to realize that
twitter
was not a medium to communicate with
your mates but was a
broadcasting medium to the whole world
these tweets by the way at the time
weren't even picked up i mean they got
sort of one and two
likes and things like that so they
didn't gain him anything but here they
are ten years later looking like they
could crash his career
the reason i say that there's something
deeply vengeful about it and disturbing
about it
is not just that element of it but
what's expected
afterwards he was
invited to read out a prepared statement
before the camera
in a scene which i thought looked
positively pyongyang-esque
as he read out his formal apology
expressed how
into diversity he actually is and so on
he was he was a young man basically sort
of begging for his career
and then uh he was suspended anyway
that's what i find so disturbing about
it it's not just the
sort of archaeological offense uh
business
it's just the fact that as i've written
quite a lot before
we live in a society that's really good
on the vengeance it's
really good on the offense archaeology
it's really good at punishing people
for airing once in a statement but we've
spent no time
thinking about how people are meant to
redeem themselves
yeah i think douglas has a very fair
point though which is ollie robinson
doesn't try and defend his remarks
and he didn't make these remarks as an
england cricketer i mean there is a
question about you know how
far back we go but there's another case
now involving
an unnamed creature and tweets he sent
before the age of 16
so how far back into people's past
are we going i also think there's
there's an element here of a lack of
media
savviness you know i i think i think if
if robinson had had
uh maybe a more worldly wise agent
around him for example he'd have said to
him look
you're gonna get a lot more media
attention playing for england than you
do playing for sussex so
i suggest you just delete all that
social media stuff you know
whatever let's not bother going back
through it to see what's there
just just delete it all i think that's
going to become a much more common
reaction
uh from people when they know that
they're about to be propelled to sudden
fame one of the other things by the way
about this that's so disturbing i think
is this
is this assumption that i mean you know
our cricketers our sportsmen
uh um you know they if they represent
the national team they do represent the
nation in some way but
they're not a clerical class i mean i
know some people
in sports these days seem to think that
they are and think that they have to
effectively preach to the terraces
but they're not a clerical class and i
have a question over
why it is that we expect them to be
these sorts of
purer than pure figures i mean
um we have a situation at the moment
where
there are mps in parliament who are
actually in our legislative bodies
who have said much worse things than
ollie robinson did ollie robinson did
this
this bad taste banter 10 years ago less
time ago than that zara sultana the
labour mp was tweeting out
anti-jewish racist remarks on twitter
now now i'm much more disturbed by
by racists uh uh um racist twitter
histories in the house of commons
than i am inappropriate banter from
members of the england cricket team
but it seems to be so easy to sort of
crush
a a young cricketer's career um hound
some sportsman or woman uh and and i
think there's something completely off
about this i don't look to the england
cricket team for morality or ethics or
behavior
i don't want any of that from i don't
want it from the terraces i don't want
it from the football teams
james let's get into the politics of
this douglas raises the double standard
point
but ministers are now getting involved
culture secretary oliver dowden said
that the cricket board went
over the top in its decision to suspend
robinson do you think he should be
intervening
i i am i must admit i am wary about
both uh the both sport getting into
politics and politics getting into sport
i mean there's a
but i think i mean this i don't that is
where this gets
gets tricky i think it would be much
healthier
if there was less politics in sport and
politicians were taking less of an
interest in this
kind of question um you know i mean
there
there are there are various countries
around the world whereas points in their
history where
you know where where the national
governments have leaned quite heavily on
the selection of the of
a of the cricket team and they're like i
mean that would obviously be
an absurd route to go down but i mean
there there is something going on here
which is
that the reaction just does seem so
disproportionate seeing that robinson
seems to be genuinely contrite for what
he said and
and i think there is a question here as
i said
how do we do forgiveness at what point
can someone say
something that is regarded as being
enough and and you know and i think
having your test match debut the
proudest moment of your career to date
you know um spoiled in this way i mean
that seems like a fairly hefty
punishment already
let's open this up slightly more widely
because it's not just oliver dowden who
jumped into the culture wars this week
gavin williamson also waded into a
debate over an oxford college that wants
to take down a picture of the queen is
this part of
number 10 strategy now james that
they're going to weigh into the culture
wars more
and perhaps they're not going to wait
for labor to prompt them to do so
i i think the government's attitudes to
culturals has always been
to wait uh to be responsive to wait for
for something to happen that
most people will consider silly this
oxford row is spectacularly stupid
uh or you've got the middle combination
room at modeling college oxford deciding
to remove a picture of the queen on the
basis that you
you can't disentangle her from uh the
state from colonialism
and if you want to go down this argument
about you know historical privilege and
all this
i think you i think you would argue that
it's impossible to disentangle modeling
college oxford from it by that logic
because
they should remove themselves um so it
is
it is a truly absurd route but i also
think that you know
but the government wading into it has a
certain savings to it because
student student unions let alone middle
combination rooms
have done dark things throughout history
and and in some ways there can't be that
much
i think i think it is remarkable but
spectacular level of interest
but this gesture and it is a gesture has
generated
it's it's a very interesting question
this
about the the culture wars and the
government uh putting into it because
there's something that i think a lot of
our viewers will be aware of that go
goes on here the left fights vicious
sectarian culture wars on a daily basis
and then whenever anyone of the right
does anything pushing back there are two
moves
that the radical left makes they either
say
oh how dare you play a culture war or
they say you're playing a culture war
against the problem that doesn't exist
which happens to be manifested daily in
their own behavior
and so when when people sort of get into
this whole sort of does
should government get engaged in it the
answer is that the government should
stand up for the traditions and the
people of the united kingdom
you know the government of the united
kingdom is not an ngo
it's not a a mere distributor of
funds in a multi national level
it is the government of the united
kingdom it should stand up for the
traditions and the
the good history of our country i think
it is
often the case that there are silly
things i agree the modern college uh
portrait is a relatively silly case
because you can always find students
doing dumb stuff
um but nevertheless when there are
serious questions
over publicly funded institutions and
the ideological drift of them
then it isn't inappropriate i think uh
for ministers and others to take an
interest you know
in a generational long leftward drift
which would be good to see stopped
douglas
some thought that brexit and donald
trump were fueling the culture wars
and the dial down of the event and the
man might allow for some breathing space
but culture wars seem to have a much
longer shelf life than many would have
thought
that's right that's right i i never
bought that argument that you know
donald trump would leave office and uh
the radical left in america would stop
pushing you know i i never
bought that um i think it's the same in
the uk there's
there's a particular ideological agenda
which the radical left has it's the same
agenda around the world they're always
pushing for the same boring things
and um everywhere the right is slightly
stymied in what its response should be
there are perfectly reasonable responses
the right can play back but
but yeah it's not as if the ideological
left was ever planning to take a break
uh simply because uh joe biden's in
office or because
the brexit agreement had been reached
james on the other side
trump certainly used the culture wars to
his advantage now that he's gone
is there just a gaping trump-sized hole
that others are trying to fill
or is there room for calmer conversation
now between the two sides to discuss how
they might tackle the big issues of the
day
i i think the remarkable thing when you
look at polling in the uk
is how small the kind of culture war
um numbers are and i think i think i
think that douglas is right about
where most of this starts and i think it
generally tends to start with
a small number of kind of highly
committed
activists on the left who push for a
bunch of things
and then you get some pushback and i
think that but i think we i think in a
way
one of the things the answer to all of
these problems to my mind
is more education not less
let's have a debate about the statues in
this country
but let's not rip them down let's
understand why they are there in the
first place
what they represent why people at the
time admired them
why people today might think differently
and i think that you know
contextualization
is is a much better approach to this
stuff
that than than trying to silence your
opponent
pull down statues no platform people i
think we can
but i i think i mean actually in the
general public
there is there is there is far more
agreement on cultural questions
uh that than than you might think i mean
that most people broadly accept that
this country has
been a force for good in the world but
it has a long history some of which is
inglorious and some of which is glorious
and i think that i mean the the public
understanding of these
these questions actually kind of much
more nuanced often than the elite
understanding
can i just because i agree with james
but just with one caveat if i may
about the polling of the public
understanding of culture wars as james
knows there's been a
several polls recently a yougov poll and
ipsos mario poll on these issues
and and they've been used by a number of
people from right and left to say the
the public doesn't really care about
culture wars issues and the reason that
people have claimed that about this
recent polling
is the relatively low number of people
who for instance particularly care
either way about particular trans issues
now there's an obvious reason for that
which is there's a very small number of
trans people in society and
the issue is directly affecting
relatively few people in any direction
so it's sort of understandable the the
reason i wanted to add the caveat is
that the exception in this is a very
high level of public awareness and
dissatisfaction
of the racialization of the rhetoric
specifically
the use of white as a pejorative term
the
uh lumping in of all white people into
one case
into one racial category and a negative
racial category at that
that's very interesting to me because it
suggests that
in a white majority country the majority
of people have
picked up on the fact that in the
culture war there are things being said
now
of a racially reprehensible nature which
rub the majority
up the wrong way and if i were the
radical left pushing some of this
cultural stuff at the moment i would
look at those polls and begin to worry
[Music]
you